я тішуся що нарешті хоч зараз силовикам
дійшли руки дослідити знайти докази яких
як на мене з 19-го року було більше ніж
достатньо щоби притягати його до
відповідальності Мені би дуже хотілося
щоб це не завершилося тільки такою
медійною афектацією А щоби це
завершилося дуже конкретними вироками і
щоби Це дало старт ще одній дуже
важливій тенденції яка на жаль не
спостерігається щоби нарешті у сесійну
залу винесли хоча би один з чотирьох а
бажано усі чотири законопроєкти які
заборонять депутатам із заборонених
партій брати участь представляти
українців як в Верховній Раді так і на
місцях я маю на увазі щоб ми позбулися
опзж та іншої гопкомпанії у усіх радах
усіх рівнів ну це це це би мало статися
і це би мало статися якнайшвидше